(upbeat music)
(Sutton laughs)
- Did I nail it, or should I do it again?
One more time?
(swishing and creaking)
(upbeat music)
Hey, I'm Hilary Duff.
- I'm Sutton Foster.
- We are the cast of Younger,
and we're here at Buzzfeed,
and we're about to play Giant Jenga.
- Yeah.
- Truth or Dare version, Giant Jenga.
You wanna go first?
(Sutton giggles)
- I guess.
I'm nervous.
(nervous muttering)
You're gonna have to speed it up.
Uh-oh, this says truth.
What do I do now?
(upbeat music)
I would work backstage at
A Doll's House, Part Two.
Just so I could see everybody act,
and I would be the backstage
person who opens the door.
- That one.
- [Sutton] Aw yeah, rocked it.
- Dare.
Oh, shit! (giggles)
(upbeat music)
Okay, let's prank call my assistant.
(dial tone ringing)
- She'll answer?
She'll answer, right?
You could say like,
"Your pizza delivery's on
the way," or something.
(laughs) I don't know,
I'm trying to think.
Oh my God, don't laugh.
You won free pizza.
- Ay ma'am, you won a free pizza.
(giggles)
- [Hilary's Assistant] Oh, sweet...
Are you guys serious?
(Hilary giggles)
- You're just getting prank
called on BuzzFeed right now.
(laughs)
- [Hilary's Assistant] I knew it!
- I am terrified about these.
- I've done it!
- Oh God, this is gonna be awful.
I'm not gonna look.
I'm scared about the dare!
- I hope you get dare,
I hope you get dare.
- But I don't like it!
Do I do it like that?
- No.
- Oh, what do I do?
Put it in the middle?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh okay, we got an in.
Truth!
Sorry.
- [Hilary] I'll get another dare.
(upbeat music)
- Probably, we have a big fight scene,
the one at the bonfire.
- [Hilary] Yeah.
- I think that was really hard.
- Really, really drunk
and emotional.
- We were drunk,
and emotional, and we had
to yell at each other.
That whole part was really hard.
All the stuff that we had to go through,
especially at the beginning of
the season, was really hard.
- Yeah.
- Cause we were fighting and stuff.
So, I didn't like that.
Oh, another one's coming out.
Oh, oh, oh!
Stress, stressing me out.
Okay.
That one feels awfully loose though.
- I really don't want dare.
Oh wow, look at that, truth!
- The dares are awful.
(upbeat music)
- No, I don't.
I don't have any plans
for any music or a tour,
this year.
But there's always next year.
- Well, this one was
loose, but it seems scary.
- Movin' for a side piece.
- Well, I'm really
nervous what this dare is,
cause I'm not good at this stuff.
Truth!
(laughs) Sorry, again.
(Hilary groans)
(upbeat music)
Sweeney Todd. (laughs)
- Are you gonna elaborate?
- No, it's completely against my type.
(laughing)
It would be fun to do
something that's unexpected.
Yeah, I don't know.
- Amanda, I'm gonna go for a dare.
- Oh, you're so brave.
(upbeat music)
- I think I was like...
(giggles)
So we have to do the thing,
and then they put it in with CGI.
Like, the mouse ears.
And then, they made us
do it like, 900 times.
- Oh my God.
- And I think I lost all
personality at that point.
Plus, I was a pubescent teen.
I was like, "What are they making me do?
This is invisible!"
(laughs)
I think I had shot the
beginning of Lizzie McGuire
with all those bouncy balls,
and I was like, "This
is a last-minute thing."
- Oh, I can't wait to watch this!
- It was so good!
- So good!
- It's Hilary with a lotta attitude.
- I'm really nervous about all of these.
Truth!
I know, these are boring.
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
Yogurt.
- Oh yeah.
- (laughs) That's all you get!
- Yogurt.
(upbeat music)
- On social media, that I've ever...
I mean, Disney Channel thing coming out,
that was pretty funny.
(blowing)
- Uh oh, it's a dare.
(laughs)
Oh God, oh God, oh God.
(upbeat music)
That's...
Okay.
- 20 seconds is a long time.
- All right.
(clock ticking)
She's a good mother,
she's nice, she's smart,
she really has a great sense of style,
she's funny, (stutters)
she's self deprecating, she's kind,
she likes to eat.
(laughing)
(timer dings)
She eats like a normal human being,
which I think is exciting.
(laughing)
- That's really nice.
(Sutton laughs loudly)
I do eat human food.
- [Sutton] You do, it's
incredibly refreshing!
- Hey guess what, you guys?
(Sutton screams)
(laughing)
We're done!
(upbeat music)
(swishing and creaking)